foreign
welcome to this new video by simply
learn are you looking for a way to cut
through the noise and identify the most
authoritative websites online for this
you will need to know the domain
authority of website domain Authority a
powerful metric that measures a site's
overall strength and influence in search
engine rankings so in this video we will
dive deep and get a detailed
understanding of domain Authority we
will cover all the aspects of domain
Authority like what domain Authority is
and the key differences between domain
Authority and Page Authority moving
ahead we will understand why domain
Authority is important and how websites
are benefited from domain Authority we
will have a look at domain Authority
score and understand whether it is good
score or not it is necessary to know
that domain Authority changes with time
and how we can calculate domain
Authority we will cover some tools that
may help in finding the domain authority
of the websites next we will have a look
at five tips to improve domain Authority
for your website but before we move
ahead in this video have a look at a
professional certificate program in
digital marketing some key features of
the program include master classes by
Purdue ask me anything sessions industry
projects and more you will be benefited
from in-depth knowledge of search engine
optimization content marketing web
analytics keyword management and
research website management and
optimization URL management keyword
research and more so what are you
waiting for hurry up and find the course
Link in the description box below so
here is a question for you domain
Authority is developed by Option 1
semrush option 2 RFS option 3 most and
option for backlinko
add your answers in the comment section
below and get a heart from Simply learn
in case you fail to answer stick to the
end of the video to learn more about
domain Authority also don't forget to
subscribe simply learns YouTube channel
and never miss any updates from Simply
learn so let's start by understanding
what domain Authority is
domain Authority is the term first
coined by Moose domain Authority or da
is the search engine ranking score that
shows How likely a website is to rank in
serps a search engine result Pages the
DS score is always between 1 to 100. the
more your website has a DS score the
higher the chances for it to rank in
serps so now you must have a question
what is the difference between domain
Authority and Page Authority the key
difference between domain Authority and
the page Authority is domain Authority
is the score for a complete domain or a
website however a page Authority is the
score for a specific page in the domain
or website moving ahead let us
understand is the domain Authority
important followed by benefits of domain
Authority importance of domain Authority
domain Authority is an important metric
as it is the easiest way to understand
the ranking potential of a website a
higher domain Authority score is
typically associated with the greater
likelihood of ranking well in search
engine result Pages which may lead to
increased traffic and visibility for the
website it can help in getting useful
insights from the competitors or
websites in the same Niche moreover
domain Authority also help in making
strategic decisions around the content
creation link building and overall
website optimization by focusing on
improving domain Authority website
owners can take a concrete steps to
enhance their online presence and
increase the their visibility and
credibility in the search engine result
Pages benefits of domain Authority the
benefits of having domain Authority
include improve search engine rankings
with higher domain Authority your
website is more likely to rank well in
serps which can lead to increased
traffic and visibility for the site next
is increased credibility a high domain
Authority score can serve as an
indicator of a website's credibility and
Authority in your industry thus it
builds trust with users and potential
customers the next we have is
competitive Advantage domain authority
of competitors or other relevant sites
will help website owners to gain
insights and identify areas for
improvement giving them a strategic
advantage in the Online Marketplace more
backlinks websites with high domain
Authority scores are more likely to
attract quality backlinks from the other
reputable sites which can further boost
their credibility and ranking power
better user experience by optimizing for
a domain Authority website owners can
focus on creating high quality relevant
content that meets the needs of the
target audience leading to a better
overall user experience and increased
engagement now that we have known the
benefits of domain Authority let's move
forward to understand more about domain
Authority score the domain authority of
any website May lie between 1 to 100
considering one to be the bad score and
100 to be a good so say for example if a
website has D820 then it needs a serious
attention and there is a need to carry
out required SEO practices however do
you know that domain Authority may
change over time yes you heard it right
domain Authority depends on various
factors like links and content these
factors can change over time and as a
result a site's domain Authority score
can fluctuate for example if a site
acquires high quality inbound links from
a reputable sources or improves the
relevance and quality of its content its
domain Authority score May increase
conversely if a site loses inbound links
or its content become outdated or
irrelevant its domain Authority score
May decrease it is important to note
that domain Authority is a relative
metric which means that changes in
domain Authority score can be influenced
by the authority of other sites in the
same Niche or in our stream as such
changes in domain Authority should be
evaluated in the context of broader
Trends and competitors within the
relevant online space now let's find out
how domain Authority is calculated
domain Authority is calculated on
various factors like root domains the
total number of links quality links
content Etc after the update of domain
authority to 2.0 it is calculated with
the help of machine learning algorithms
the work goes as say if x website
appears in search results more
frequently than website y then website X
must have higher da compared to website
y let's now wrap up top 5 tips to
improve the domain Authority tip number
one create high quality relevant content
one of the most important factor in
domain Authority is the relevance and
the quality of content on the site by
creating original well-researched
content that meets the needs and
interests of the audience you can
attract quality inbound links and
increase your site's overall Authority
moving ahead with tip number two build
quality inbound links inbound links from
reputable High Authority sites are an
important factor in domain Authority
focus on building quality and bound
links through the tactics like guest
blogging influencer Outreach and social
media promotion with inbound links it is
also necessary to have on-page
optimization of pages on the website
on-page SEO factors like title tags meta
descriptions and header tags can help
search engines understand the relevance
and importance of your content by
optimizing your sites on page SEO you
can improve your site's own overall
Authority and ranking power with this
you also need to carry out good keyword
research keyword research can help you
to identify topics or freezes relevant
to your target audience by targeting
these keywords in your content you can
improve your site's Authority and
relevance the next step we have is to
improve the site speed and usability a
first user-friendly website can improve
engagement and help to build Authority
with both users and search engines focus
on optimizing site speed and usability
through tactics like image optimization
caching and responsive design moving to
the last step monitor your progress and
adjust strategy domain Authority is a
relative metric which means that it can
be changed over time based on the
authority of other sites in yarnish or
industry monitor your site's domain
authority over time and adjust your
strategy based on Trends and competitive
analysis well these tips will definitely
help you to improve your site's domain
Authority however here we have some
bonus tips for you tip number one
leverage social media social media can
be a valuable tool for building
authority and driving traffic to your
site focus on building a strong social
media presence and sharing high quality
content that resonates with your target
audience next is audience engagement
engage your audience through comments
social media and other channels building
relationships with your audience can
help to increase engagement and build
Authority next is monitor your analytics
monitor your site's analytics to
identify area of strengths and
weaknesses use this information to
adjust your strategy and focus on the
tactics that are most effective in
building authority keep your site
updated regularly update your site with
fresh content and keep it up to date
with the latest trends and practices in
your industry the can help to maintain
relevance and build authority over time
now the question arises how we can check
whether the domain Authority is improved
or not we can do this with the help of
tools like most link Explorer ahrefs
semrush Majestic and Google search
console concludingly domain Authority is
a critical metric that can have a
significant impact on your website's
search engine rankings and overall
visibility by improving your domain
Authority these tactics like creating
high quality content building quality
inbound links and optimizing for SEO you
can establish yourself as leader in your
industry and attract more potential
customers to your site while improving
domain Authority takes time and effort
the benefits are well worth it with a
strong domain Authority you can increase
your organic search traffic improve your
Brand's visibility and drive more lead
and sales to your business so if you are
looking to improve your website's
Authority and take your online presence
to Next Level consider implementing some
of the tips and strategies we have
discussed in this video with the right
approach and commitment to building
quality content and links you can
improve your domain Authority and
Achieve long-term success online so here
we wrap up this topic soon we will come
up with another interesting topic on SEO
till then stay tuned with simply learn
and do not forget to like And subscribe
and share this video thanks for watching
this video
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here